[Music]
it's not a drill
then
you warn out here my daughters with me
dad let's go can you tell me where you
live in the park
there's 435 questions respond true/false
to each question who taught you how to
read my dad teaches me you're actually
quite a bit ahead of where you need to
be I wake up rested and peaceful most
morning true my day-to-day life is full
of things that keep me interested true I
have nightmares or troubling dream is
your dad in the service yours
do you feel safe living with your dad we
didn't need to be rescued your dad needs
to provide you shelter and a place to
live he did it's not a crime to be in
house but it's illegal to live on public
land we have found an option we're gonna
be okay here I just don't think our own
thoughts
look we want to go
school is about social skills not just
intellectual ones think it might be
easier unless if we try to adapt wearing
the clothes in the house reading the
food we're doing their work
we have adapted
thank you thanks
did you even try so I can tell somebody
so to speak
wish a home with my dad
I don't wanna leave same thing that's
wrong with you isn't wrong with me
well you guys have it I don't think they
knew where we were going
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you